welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the master of
unlocking
and explaining resident evil village has
a lot to unpack from its ending
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything you need to
know about this story
in all its gory the game changes a lot
of the established lore
sets up what's to come and packs some
big twists that also
impact a lot of the previous games full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to play the game yet then you
best get out of here
before i make you into a jill sandwich
please click the thumbs up button if you
don't want to become my nemesis
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns worth coming back to life 4.
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into our resident
evil 8 ending explained
okay so up top i'm going to be going to
the general plot point of the game
but if you want to skip ahead then time
codes will be linked below
the game itself is set three years after
the events of resident evil 7
and much like that game we see things
through the perspective of everyone's
favorite blank slate
ethan winters ethan is a bit of a weird
one for me
as i never found the guy all that
interesting in the previous game
he's very much in every man but what
resident evil 8 does
is that it injects some new life into
him there's a big twist about his past
and i have to say that when i learned it
i did find him slightly more interesting
now it turns out that ethan actually
died right at the beginning of resident
evil 7
after his first encounter with jack
becket however the mould on the estate
which
transformed them two did the same thing
with ethan
and since then he's pretty much been a
bioweapon capable of surviving almost
every kind of injury it's a nice little
twist that explains why he's able to
have his hands cut off more times than
anakin skywalker
and makes the character far more
interesting than he initially was
the game itself opens with ethan living
with mia
and their daughter rosemary out of
nowhere a newly designed chris redfield
appears
wearing a turtleneck and trench coat not
only does he commit several fashion
crimes
he also murders mia and takes ethan and
rosemary to a village located in
transylvania
it's not the best trip i've ever been on
i must admit and i would have given it
one start on tripadvisor
if it wasn't for the new character lady
double d
a nine foot tall vampire now i'll get
into hurt in just a bit
but chris of course appeared at the end
of resident evil 7 with the bsaa
and he helped to rescue ethan in the
three years and seven chris was actually
paramount in aiding mia and ethan and
hiding away from the nefarious forces
that were behind the events of that game
so this twist comes completely out of
the blue the game clearly paints him out
as a bad guy early on
but as we get into it we discover that
it's not all that black and white
chris actually has a big mission in the
village which of course becomes the key
location
that the game is set in the area itself
is overseen by several mutants who
control their own parts of the village
and this area becomes the hub in which
ethan must battle through their forces
all whilst attempting to find pieces of
his daughter who has been separated and
placed into tiny
flasks how this is possible is because
she has inherited the mold abilities
present in her parents
and thus can withstand being broken up
into little parts
it all gets a bit weird now lady
dimetrescu who i'm to be calling
lady d from now on because i don't want
to butcher her name
is absolutely everywhere in the
marketing but when it comes to the game
itself
she doesn't appear that much i was kind
of hoping she would be something in the
same vein of mr x or nemesis where the
character would stalk and hunt you
throughout the game
but the vampiric vixen is in for a very
short time
there's also carl heisenberg who leads
the werewolves that roam the area
moreau who is an amphibious creature and
donna who can control a creepy puppet
called angie
at the head of these houses is mother
miranda a mysterious figure who is
worshipped by the locals as a deity
ethan encounters these early on after
the transport to transylvania
is destroyed and he ends up venturing
into the village to see the horrors
first hand
ethan works through the world killing
all the heads of the houses
and he discovers that heisenberg is
planning a rebellion against miranda
so that he can take over and turn it
into one big b
b heisenberg wants to use rosemary to
win
but ethan of course refuses to hand his
daughter over
and the pair fight now through this
story we learn that chris
isn't actually a bad guy and when ethan
confronts him we discover what the
beginning of the game was
actually about it turns out that he
didn't kill mia and the person he
seemingly murdered was actually miranda
just posing as her aranda faked her own
death
and managed to escape from the home and
it was her who crashed the transport
with ethernet
so that she could take rosemary it turns
out that rosemary can be used as
somewhat of a vessel
and miranda wants to bring back a
certain character through her
chris and ethan end up working together
and they defeat heisenberg
but miranda arrives and kills ethan by
ripping his heart out
with everything left on chris's
shoulders he launches an attack with his
special forces
the bsaa also arrive which is very
important to bear in mind
for the end of the game they go off to
fight miranda on their own
separate from chris and there's also a
lot more going on with them than meets
the eye
in the cavernous areas of the village
chris finds the source of the mold
that he learns created evelyn chris
plants a bomb on it
and travels deeper into the cave which
is where he discovers the truth about
miranda
and the monsters in the village turns
out that miranda and her daughter eva
actually lived at the beginning of the
20th century and
when the world was ravaged by spanish
flu the latter sadly died
miranda experimented on the mold and
through doing so
found a way to become immortal miranda
gained all kinds of abilities through
this
including the power to shape shift and
change certain parts of her body
these mutations have of course been
present throughout several of the
monsters in the series so far
showing that as you guessed it's all
connected
now she wished to bring eva back to life
and experimented on several of the
villages
which resulted in the werewolves or
other lycans
the four houses and of course evelyn
evelyn was viewed as a failure due to
not really being either
and thus the work continued miranda was
unable to find the perfect host
until rosemary came along who of course
inherited
special abilities from her mother and
father they do a big retcon where it
turns out that miranda was actually
linked in with umbrella
and that she mentored its founder oswell
e spencer
the corporation of course created the
bio weapons and zombies that have been
stapled throughout the series
and whether you like it or not this is
now the canon of resident evelyn
now spencer branched off to do his own
thing and he ventured to africa to work
on creating the t-virus
the umbrella logo however is dotted
throughout the village
and this is because spencer stole the
icon and just added some color to it
get their trademark lawyers in now it's
here that chris also discovers mia
and he learns that ethan is alive ethan
ends up fighting against miranda
and he manages to save rosemary however
because he's taken
a bigger battering than this video's
dislike button because of all the crap
puns
he's unable to recover and the character
starts to die for real this time
he says goodbye to his daughter and
tells chris to take care of her
and get the hell out of there ethan
detonates the bomb planted on the core
which destroys the entire area and of
course himself
chris mia and rosemary make it out but
there are a lot of questions still up in
the air
now in the game chris learns that the
bsaa will actually buy a weapons
themselves
and he travels with his squad to the
headquarters of the organization
in order to get to the bottom of it now
i do think that the next game
will come with the reveal that it is now
company policy that the bsa
use bioweapons these seem similar to the
tyrant and are likely people that have
been experimented on
whereas the bio weapons were once
mindless monsters that could not be
controlled
over the series we have seen how things
have evolved through ethan
he showed that it is possible to have
extraordinary abilities
and still be okay i know that they did
it with wesker and his son jake too
and this cemented that you could remain
relatively human
jake started to help the fight against
bioweapons and couple this with ethan
and you can see why the bsaa might have
come round on them
this speaks into what happens in the
post-credits scene of the game
which is where we join rosemary who's
visiting ethan's grave
several years have passed at this point
and due to the way she looks
i'd say it's been 15 years at the very
least however it is possible that
because of the mold
she has aged slightly differently but
let me know below if you think that or
not
either way some time has passed and we
discovered that she is actually working
for the bsaa
which hammers home the latter point she
says that she's been busy with tests
and though this initially seems like
it's to do with school
a horn honks on a nearby suv and she
says speak of the devil
this means the tests are linked with the
bsaa
who have arrived to pick her up chris is
nowhere to be seen here
and the agent who is gives a snarky
remark and calls her evelyn
i think it's very much hints that the
bsaa don't really respect the
bio-organic population
and very much view them as simply
weapons which could hint to them
becoming somewhat villainous the next
time around
there's even some dialogue over the
radio between the agents
in which we learn that there's a sniper
standing by ready to shoot rosemary in
case things escalate
to me it's clear that ever sorry
rosemary wants to live a normal life
and do things apart from her past she
has been likely mentored by chris
and has learned a lot of things that he
doesn't even know she is capable of
however chris has enlisted her on this
mission to fight bioweapons
and this has meant she's been forced
into a life of servitude
she looks completely miserable in this
finale i think that in the next game we
will see her breaking free of this
organization
in order to do her own thing they could
potentially hunt her
or perhaps even use her for a mission
and then maybe attempt to exterminate
her
once it's complete rose marie clearly
has a target on her back
and it's even possible that she has some
connection to her father
in the game we learn that the mold acts
as somewhat of a backup for people and
their personalities
this is how miranda would have been able
to bring her daughter back
even though she was dead thus it is
possible that ethan could return in some
form
or be present in his daughter's memory
the alien says that she's a lot like her
father
and she replies i know even though she
wouldn't have been old enough to
remember him now this could simply be
because they both possess
powers but she does flip out at being
called evelyn
and at the end of resident evil 7 we did
discover that jack was able to
communicate with ethan
through the mold making me think that
rose marie may have some connection with
them that we don't know about
evelyn was also able to do this
cementing that you can speak to the
memories and manifestations of people
that exist within the substance rosemary
visited ethan's grave
and spoke to him like he was there and
though this is typical in mourning
it could be hinting at her ability to
communicate with the character
potentially a lot of reaching going on
here but either way it seems that the
next game will likely center around
rosemary and chris
because ethan was gone he likely became
her father figure
and potentially we will see her breaking
free of his control
i know he's a good guy but it looks like
they're overstepping the mark if they're
sending snipers after rosemary
in case she steps out of line either way
a lot of things up in the air and i know
i've said that already
but the game ends with the car driving
down the road however if you look very
closely you can see a mysterious figure
going to meet it
and the car stops in order to pick this
person up now this could be chris
or even the sniper hell it might even be
jake
but this seems like such a weird way to
end the game that i think it has some
importance
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on who you think this is and the game
itself
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize during the 30th of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla vs kong collection
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on resident evil village
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
jupiter's legacy which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over the entire series and
talked about the comic book changes
so definitely check it out if you want
to know more by the way thank you for
sending through the video
i've been poor i'll see you next time
take care peace